what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome
Auntie Jenny thank you
before we start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in subscribe to
the channel and bring that notification
Bell okay guys so today we are reacting
to some really reasonable women yep
tongue-in-cheek super reasonable
um women that are always very fair to
men and women yeah just you know what
put it on the put it on the screen
blessing this is the view
is really angry on the right no no
they're super reasonable they're super
reasonable is that is that one of the
Spice Girls yeah I actually don't know
it's performing it's like a Spice Girl
on the lip is that huh it's gonna make
me seem old before her time places for
my time okay is that before your time as
well blizzard
the state of Delaware is experimenting
with a new type of child support in a
form of a card which works much like an
EBT card okay the child support card
will prohibit parents from paying for
certain items like gas rent and adult
clothing and liquor and liquor
uh Lonnie what do you think what are you
thinking is this a good idea well I mean
you know what okay this is a thing that
I know about child support like you know
child support goes to the one that's the
major caregiver and um I think it's good
that they do have the card they have
certain restrictions but I also want to
say that if you are the parent and you
you're a parent if you have a child 24 7
there's nothing wrong if it's your day
off to take fifty dollars and go have a
meal I think that's okay that's okay but
some people take advantage of it yeah as
long as you don't take it everybody
take your fifty dollars and go and buy
the meal I mean I think the difference
is is that if you were if you were
married that'd be different because it'd
be the family's money but once it's been
allocated for that child it's for that
child well it's wrong to spend money
like if I gave you fifty dollars for
something and you spent it on something
else that's wrong yeah I always just say
to the fathers you know you know don't
don't ever give the parents don't ever
give they ever don't give the women the
money always buy vouchers or buy the
clothes or get the food delivered to the
house so that's what's wanted but try
not to and if you do make sure there's a
paper trail because like she said you
could be paying for a meal out why
should she why she get rewarded for
being a single parent no that's a I'm I
don't think that you should get more
money based on child custody because
then it incentivizes you not to give 50
50 custody because you're paid to but
then she's still taking that money from
I think that's a great idea Fair because
you know
you're not paying a lot in child support
a lot is relative so it might not be a
lot to you because you you work on The
View and you're paid the big bucks but
to an average person a couple hundred
bucks like that's it's not a little bit
how many miles is she enough to cut
child's support
why
'd you say
I just said you know a day out or
something she's talking about a meal do
you need it obviously not I you
are but I'm talking about where I'm from
you know the D
that 300 a week is come on bro come on
bro wait that's what that's a thousand
two hundred a month listen depending on
where you are even if it was a hundred
pounds 100 a month to certain people
that's a lot to certain people that
makes a big difference so it doesn't
that's because somebody's you can't if
you can't take it for somebody who's
getting 300 why would you want to borrow
50 like 50 when someone's gonna get 1500
because you don't know the out the
outlays the hours might be the same you
know one might go by bus one might go
far live far away from school and I need
to get transport so you can't say oh
this one's getting such and such and
that one's getting so and so because
you're not going to go until our top
earner pay 300 and you're not gonna go
on 10 a bin man or trash managers I'll
call it go and pay three thousand
dollars you're not well and a lot of
times what will happen is
um a guy well let's say he's making 80
000 a year right and he lives in in like
downtown London right he is not allowed
to quit his job
um because he needs to keep making the
child support payments and what will
happen is the the woman will move
outside of the city so they can get more
for their Buck right and he wants to
quit his job to move to them but he
can't because of the child support
payments and a lot of times like men can
be jailed for not paying child support
the Cleveland gets sucked that's that's
the that's the loop hoe yeah don't lick
don't quit your job get sacked it's
totally different I'm telling you I know
but you I think you still have to go to
court to to get it switched right so
let's say you have three months until
you actually go to court and get it
switched you still owe for the last
three months and so a lot of times like
if you're paying I don't know two grand
a month that's six grand if you're
unemployed okay I'll see if they can
backtrack it to my waist Loops as soon
as you get as soon as you get sacked
tell the Colts straight away that's what
you do I know Samantha have done that
because the women are just waiting more
and more and more and more and more
because if the men are getting
especially if the men are working hard
and getting motive they seem to want
more and more so the hearts of the man
works the more he's paying so all you've
got to do is mess up and get sacked and
go abroad
is because sadly you guys there are
those ladies there are a lot more people
that are taking women there's one of
them on the stage because I've seen this
what do you mean you've seen this before
yeah well it's yeah it's horrible
advantage of child support and that's
why they put this into action that's why
they're coming up with this idea because
you can't take your girlfriends out for
drinks on your child support
that's true yeah
it becomes a time when you as the parent
you have rights especially if you're
paying child support you have visitation
why don't we start talking to each other
as parents and as I because women drag
men to court so why Chef you could you
could just you could just talk to him
but you women drag it out in court but
the thing is why what's that got to do
with the the card
she just totally went off track
[Applause]
I think it depends on yeah but women lie
because she's saying like why don't we
just talk to each other about where the
money's going but I'm like women women
lie did she say 50 in the mail
she wouldn't would she the person and
the type of situation because there are
women out there this is the real their
fathers who search for the dudes that
have the money and say you know what
that's a whole different level that's
child support
level women do do that absolutely they
take advantage of of the situation but I
think when you look at a bill of a
mother who's charging things uh using
child support money moms also deserve to
to be able to take care of themselves
and to be able to spend on themselves
like if a mom is going to the gym she
needs to get a workout
yeah okay but you're that's entitled for
the thing you're you're allowed to spend
on yourself with your money
why does why does he gotta pay for your
gym membership to get your body right
for your next boyfriend if it's not for
the child then don't use the money on it
that's mad deserve imagine imagine
what's the word entitled and imagine a
woman or a man saying this I deserve to
spend money on myself and trying to milk
a girl for child support imagine that's
crazy
if a mom is going to go get a drink with
child support money she should get that
drink
I don't know about getting a drink on
child support if your mother you
absolutely deserve a nice little drink
of happy hour
[Applause]
with your money yeah you deserve it with
your money who's watching the kid at
happy hour that's my question the Dad's
because he's paying for the happy hour
spend your own money on yourself well he
needs to spend his money on you he wants
to be a kit woman
with my own money don't take advantage
I'm in two minds I do think there are
people out there that need to be checked
yes right they do because I have given
child support to my other half and I've
been given child support back okay now
I'm the kind of parent you know I have
three kids I make sure my kids are
treated equally as equally as possible
but when they need clothes and things
like that it's good to be able to have
that batch of money for that now I'm
kind of one of the ones that uses it
wisely because I I have money that I can
go out and get
so I'm in two minds I think some people
do need to be checked and some people
don't need to be checked
but where is the line that's why some of
these answers are so disingenuous
because they don't talk about where the
line is is that what you know who needs
to be chipped and who doesn't yeah or
maybe the money that is taken for the
children should be spent on the children
because I mean she was she was a mother
that didn't spend the money on herself
so the according to her rules she
wouldn't need to be checked but the one
in the red that wants the wine and the
gym she needs to be changed everything
have you ever used the child support
inappropriately does it happen no I
don't I don't think yeah
means
so what they're trying to say now is
that those who have money won't spend
the child's support on themselves but
those who don't have money will spend it
on themselves which doesn't make sense
because the whole point of you getting
child support is because you haven't got
the money and there's this like
narrative that somehow rich people are
like morally Superior to poor people
that's what they're insinuating rich
people steal too not child support
you know you know how many Rich Kids I
know that used to Rob Walmart when their
parents like in my high school there's
there's girls that went to this high
school it's called Barrington and
barrington's like the the nice High
School in the area like it is so nice
and freaking
um this one girl and they lived in like
a five bedroom house the nicest house
she had everything paid for one of the
most spoiled girls I know we I went to
Walmart with her once this girl was like
wearing stuff out of Walmart that she
bought so through yeah and I was just
like
me I'm like why would you and it will
not too
I was just like why would you I remember
like that was the first time I ever saw
someone steal something yeah no I was
shocked I'm sweaty and I start thinking
are they gonna think I'll move them I
tried to isolate yourself from them and
try to it's like oh I have to go toilet
or you go I'm coming I'm just looking at
something yeah
and that's what I'm saying like if
they're poor they're rich it doesn't
mean one is gonna steal more than the
other like yeah so like so I Know Rich
girls that yeah they had no reason to
steal anything imagine if they're rich
girls and they had this so they were
rich girls anyway they had their own
money and they had this extra card with
money on oh exactly oh my God I grew up
with girls like that yeah because yeah
oh my gosh I I'm like a perfect case
study because I grew up around like
Suburban because my high school I
wouldn't say was super rich but where I
went to Club volleyball like that was
you had to pay a couple thousand to play
so all the girls there were really
wealthy but a lot of them had their
parents credit cards and yeah oh my gosh
there's oh you're giving me flashbacks
this one girl or there was like tricks
they would do to get cash like say that
they didn't have the card to their dad
so their dad would give them money and
then just pay with the card because
their dad's not paying attention you
know it's like rich but yeah they would
do this stuff all the time and there's
no need to it's just full seeking
ingredients or if it was only for food
they would go to like a specific store
that had clothes and food and just say
oh it's a food bill yeah I hope they
have become single parents and spend the
child's child support
like well I felt I deserved a little
splurge on an outfit so I used that does
that really no no you know what where
I'm really getting to with this is that
because they said that they were also
checking the sizes and the ages well
maybe you are a person that has maybe
two or three kids and maybe one father
doesn't take care of the other one okay
which is not there yeah but the point is
what do you mean it's not their fault
like this is the
everything in life is your own fault if
you're a single mother that's your own
fault you made a choice to get there so
why are we rewarding people that made
poor choices like I didn't get pregnant
by no deadbeat dad no she's saying it
because the child don't get no money
from that parent it's not their fault so
split it around no sorry eat your day
around and she has a child and the
father can't support the child and so
you've got three children two of them
are getting that money in the cards and
the other one the father don't give a
damn well that one who's forever don't
give them that's your responsibility
because the other two are looking after
their children
like um
the the McDonald's man oh right right
think about the situation I think they
should pay me for not having a kid
I'm just saying if they're gonna pay all
these like the single mothers and reward
them for like getting pregnant by these
deadbeats I think I should be paid for
making the right decision then I should
be paid for yourself in one then I'm
making at this old Prime yeah yeah
where's our money
foreign
as a parent or a mother you may want to
buy the other child something with it
and that's what I'm saying is that there
are different reasons why okay I have a
solution for you get pregnant by one man
one and if you have to have more than
one look after your children
yourself
you push them out you know that's one
thing you can always guarantee my mom
said to me I always know who the mother
is when you have a baby I've heard is
that a thing where guys will like go
back to their baby mothers because they
want the same mother when they want
another kid I've heard that yeah there's
people like right in their head those
couples are sick look at it's not
they're crazy couples is that what I
would sign up for personally you know
I'm sorry but if I have three children
or different fathers no if I was a
father and I was unfortunate to have a
baby mother of three different baby
fathers hell no I don't want my money
going towards if I want to buy something
for the other children fine but why
should somebody supports supporting
somebody else's
I just thinking I knew someone had done
that they supported everybody's child
the whole damn family oh couldn't
oh God you were just like yeah you buy
for one you buy for all and I thought
okay
fine I don't
I don't think so they're trying to
budget and everything so I'm just
concerned about the restrictions on the
car that's all is there any way
that I think the only thing you'd have a
problem with you've got some children
that um
if they go in accordance to the age
my Glam daughter she's six and she takes
like a she's got very long legs like if
it was a child like you there's no way
we should be wearing trousers that are
you for your age you normally go like
two sizes up but then it can be proven
you know look at the child she's got
long legs she'll suck a giraffe that's
why it's not in her age range but if
you've got like a a seven-year-old and
then all of a sudden you're buying
clothes for a two-year-old on on the
bill that mother should be charged and
made to pay it all back I agree with you
okay
decisions why
why hey for your poor choices I think
he's paying for his kid but he shouldn't
be paying for her every man should pay
for his child but not for the mother I
don't think men should be forced to pay
for their children as long as abortion's
legal I think they should be made to pay
for them as long as I know the child was
there they accepted the child the issue
though you're going to have in court is
that there's incentive from the judges
to say it costs more to raise a kid than
it does because they get it cut out of
everything so if there was like a way to
do that in a way that was fair and
didn't discriminate against men
um I could potentially see it but I just
think the way it is now I haven't seen
someone do it in a fair way I think that
if you get to after guys he's got a
child for somebody sensible there's no
need to go to court and a lot I found
that I know a lot of people in England
are single parents and the child they
get supported and they've never been to
court well I just think the more
bailouts we give women like because it
allows girls to have kids by crazy
people and then oh it's okay I can just
take him to court and get money but it's
like if they didn't have that bailout
they might avoid the situation
altogether I think you have a child you
pay for it but I think there should be a
limit and I think that every single
penny should be chased I think there
should be a paper trail for everything I
don't think that you know you're going
to go out there and buy like a 500 pound
jacket for the kid I think that's
ridiculous but then it goes back to who
decides how much it costs to raise a kid
and it's like they're always going to be
trying to raise that number like
politicians are always going to Pander
you know they should do they should look
and see what the father's wearing look
and see what the mother's wearing and
then they should decide I think that's
what they should do because you'll find
that mothers they were shopping Walmart
but they want um Gucci for their child I
just think it's not it's not like oh let
the father buy the stuff what let the
father buy the stuff I'm trying these
clothes like the father deliver the
clothes if the child if he needs food
don't put money in the woman's hand full
stop no see I'm not I think a man should
pay for his kid if he gets a girl
pregnant I just have issues I haven't
seen a way they've done it fairly
bringing it to court it always just
seems like the men get the short end of
the stick I think that they should
provide for the child but providing
doesn't necessarily mean again I think
once you once you can say that you
you're sending food for the child the
child's will clothe if you've got to pay
for the school fees but I'm a person
that doesn't believe in putting money in
a woman's hand
I don't think you should I've always
told all of my single male friends if
they've got kids out there all say like
you know they say oh she said that Sean
is a coat that's the child's size get a
you know or get a voucher for the
store for that coat if she wants to go
and bite get a voucher or do it online
and get it delivered but put in money in
a woman's in any parent's hand I just
think no you've got a child you provide
and provide doesn't always mean money so
I'm against I'm not against men
providing I'm against them giving money
check that it's that's why I say it
depends on on the person because the
people who take advantage of the
situation shouldn't penalize the women
who actually use it for the right and I
guess also for me oh no well I have a 16
year old and she's the same size as me
so if I was going to be buying for my 16
year old if I was in that situation
[Laughter]
no I suppose what you need to do is if
you've got teenage kids face Slim
[Laughter]
imagine Lonnie Love trying to stay slim
who's that that's the big girl okay that
is outside oh that one that was on there
yeah I think Liza's a bit bigger but
it's like she's like they're still whale
territory I just think don't don't put
money in a woman's hand because I think
that I might be wrong I I know that in
England if you can show that you're
providing for the child I don't think
there's a lot of people can do the the
difference is when they stop providing
for the child and that gives bitter
women to go and say he's not doing this
this and this and a lot of men make the
mistake of once they have a child they
give the woman money
and then when if the woman gets bitter
that's how come the men lose out because
the women go to court and they'll say he
doesn't give me any money and then he'll
say yes I am and they'll say where's the
evidence because there is this is the
cash yeah so don't give cash put money
in the bank account vouchers get stuff
delivered no cash
okay guys um let me know what you guys
think in the comments um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel I thought they
were crazy as usual
um I thought there's maybe one or two
that had some base points but overall I
just think there's a lack of seeing
men's point of view a lot of the time on
these shows I just didn't get the whole
gym bottle of wine dinner thing I've
never heard something so crazy you know
you get child support why can't I have a
drink after the long day I'm a mother
you know why can't I go to the gym I
wanna look good at running after the
kids our grandmothers would just think
we were so soft can you imagine they're
like churning butter they're great
grandmas and and they're like
Chutney bar for years ago people thought
I was weird and and you know you know
now we got we got roombas
we got washing machines dishwashers I
still complain about what a long day
they have still complaining but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell like the
video on your way out and I will talk to
you next time